comme on a kiffé on a kiffé je vous le
dis on a utilisé de se mettre tous en
manga longs mois je suis le plus pourri
je vous dis mon mieux en d'olive et tom
on comprend pas franchement mais il y en
a qui sont très bien on va cueillir tout
de suite jeanne et serge c'est parti
merci j'avais dit que j'étais le plus
pourri j'ai oublié honey bee merci merci
pour escada commissaire saby rôle des
génériques et de néris-les-bains
latulippe le générique et 16
[Applaudissements]
dans l'équipe il ya maintenant une fille
qui a du punch
ls merci tu vas sortir alors on va
maintenant accueillir est ce que vous
connaissez ken sienne mais il est avec
nous ken le survivant
vous allez voir la zone est chez nous
alors vous voyez ken le survivant c'est
ça vous allez voir chez le ken le
survivant
on dirait un acteur de films x
[Applaudissements]
je les connais votre famille vous
regarde
malheureusement comme dirait un bond à
merci il est plus à l'est alors on va
voilà bah ouais alors la cocaïne c'est
goldorak
c'est ça alors goldorak chez nous le
costume est arrivé tard taabo dernier il
est 19 heures 22 on est en direct voilà
goldorak
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce casque il se cache derrière goldorak
qui se clôt costumés pas semblant
[Musique]
écoutez agréé goldorak la belle année
2010 parce que le mec qui chante et ça
plaît et il s'appelle nous sommes je
crois mon frère il a une voix mon frère
on dirait et il a une voix de tunisiens
mais de ouf
mais regardez écoutez sans déconner il
traverse et non lui l'hiver on dirait le
rapt de benali tarabella seibert ça nous
va très bien les joues un peu mal
coiffée comme ça ah ouais décoiffé quoi
way benhaim en ce moment elle est comme
ça je peux vous dire je sais quelle part
un petit peu en vacances avec patoche
pendant les vacances
al ahly ils vont pas faire beaucoup de
visites les parents je vous ai dit que
j'allais faire des musées vous avez ri
bassirou le musée ou à mon avis au musée
jeu c'est terminé c'est bon je vais pas
en parler
on sait très bien ce que vous faites
benhaim vous êtes salle bénin n ont pas
pu accueillir tout de suite albator
je ferai
alors pourquoi pourquoi tu as le truc là
et tu fermes l'autre oeil
il est comme ça il est fermé le deuil
que le cordon de tombes dans l'oeil
le cordon autonome a gâché je vous jure
voulu reprendre les grappes merci le
personnage
allez maintenant ça fait plaisir car si
on a fait ça pour autant sa faiblesse
est-ce que je vais tout de suite c'est
un honneur c'est un vrai bonheur on a
kiffé et je vous jure je le redis tous
les spécialistes de manga gars l'ont
adoré ouais je sais c'est un peu sa vie
s'il va mieux après sa spécialiste le
qui oblige ils brûlent minable je les ai
vus il est formidable parce que vous
réinventer le genre c'est moderne c'est
super bien décider le scénario est
innovant pour toutes les générations de
la famille moi tout le monde se les
arracher déjà formé et le alors essayez
o'shea y ajouta mois qu'on embrasse mais
c'est vrai c'est moi qui ai gagné le
shiatsu tamouls auraient aimé que vous
l'avez vous connaissez c'est un japonais
je me doutais que c'était quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
les sociétés et ce dernier est donc est
donc comment vous avez approché les
équipes de ma wen en disant qu'ils vont
présenter mis en contact mis en contact
mais il est bon à froid oui je vous jure
c'est toutes les critiques sont très
très bonnes voilà je vous le dis pas
pour noël ça en jetterait bon coup
d'oeil
pendant que vous faites ça plus ça en
fait et vous faites et vous mettez en
plus à celle et de deutsch ou vous avez
tout là on va cueillir away à merde
c'est lui je sais les chevaliers du
zodiaque mais ils ont pris un coup dans
la gueule
zyva dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mali j'ai compris qu'ils me détestaient
qu il fallait que je mette sa bane et je
crois que mamie je crois que tu es
bourré et on refait son entrée c'est
quoi en campagne avec à la une paris
alors et maître gims
tu as maigri
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maître gims à dégager ce truc là ce n
est pas beau son petit frère hossam et
non mais ils sont tous beaux dans cette
vallée lâcher chez vous vous allez voir
et les dessins sans même le manga est
vraiment son rôle son talentueux risotto
fouet mais vraiment et la voix de maître
gims ça va être bon et aux critiques la
voix de maître gims ça bouffe c'est une
des plus belles voix que j'ai entendu de
la loi evin en bas je sais moi ya cette
voie et la voix de gilles verdez on a
sailor moon a laissé partir dadis et
leur ramène toi
k
villa
elle me touche c'est qu'elle le fait
premier degré le cas si gwen un casting
pour cela elle est arrivée elle en
premier elle est persuadée qu'elle est
laide ou son directeur un casting pour
celle en bouteille sais pas si je vais y
arriver je peux te dire je suis à fond
les ballons ça va commencer entraîner
alors franchement bravo vous avez poussé
bravo qui dit on à elle a bossé en temps
c'est ça le truc elle fut pendant
l'émission sous bois alors vous et je
vous dis la vérité je vous aime beaucoup
les glaces
vous êtes tellement dégueulasse que
j'étais vous je premier mais là c'est un
truc de ouf je sais est d'habitude ces
produits concluent au delà du sac
je me rendais compte vous rendez compte
que ya huit ans était le beau gosse de
l'émission
ap l'intello
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas un coup de pelle qui la
primaire c'est tout le jardin était tout
va et tout va c'est jean tiberi tu vas
voir demande vers en laponie d'aller
voir un moment on le voit un petit peu
dénudée dans son lit pour popopopop on
est bien négocié ses chroniqueurs doit
vous avez fait mais les chroniqueurs
dénudées oui oui qui veut de vous merci
revoit que ya maintenant à oui je sais
qu'il y en a
alors ouais bah ouais c'est pokémon
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on pourra voir le truc est claire à ce
qu'on peut
[Applaudissements]
alors nicky larson les musclés
tranquille
ils sont passés
[Musique]
dans le cossu est d'ailleurs elle 6
février
ça va sortir nicky larson près je mets
les auteurs de l'émission l'ont vu ils
ont adoré mais surtout comment tu passes
derrière maxime tu peux paradis virtuel
games et la bulgarie la turquie
allez on a avoué est maintenant aller à
huawei
on est obligé de recevoir sangoku de
dragon ball z
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dentelle dans lequel dans quel épisode
on a vu dragon ball non non c'est quoi
l'album bonne éviter ou non mais ça
rigolait parce que dragonball qu'il fait
ça je le savais je dois avouer
dragonball fox 2000 à la dragon ball
contre mylène farmer
non
interprétation du personnage
ces différences de pas toucher les les
japonais qui a touché
[Applaudissements]